c'est une explosion très impressionnante
qu'il ya eu lieu au petit matin une
maison particulière a été totalement
soufflés et vous le voyez les dégâts
sont énormes
on ne reconnaît plus rien de la maison
est en ce moment une équipe de sapeurs
pompiers est en train de déblayer
à l'intérieur se trouvait un couple
d'une soixantaine d'années l'homme a été
plus durement touchés il a été transféré
à l'hôpital de lyon en état d'urgence
absolue le gaz serait à l'origine du
sinistre en est le matin de bonne heure
les deux personnes sont en pyjama dans
ta sont au lit ou au lever il est
possible qu'une accumulation de da soit
produite pendant la nuit alors défaut
d'aération ou par fluide mais ça c'est
une enquête qui tentera de déterminer
l'explosion a beaucoup choqué dans le
voisinage proche même si personne
d'autre n'a été blessé elle a été
entendue jusque marmagne soit à 6 km à
la ronde
le maire du creusot déploie tous les
moyens nécessaires notamment une cellule
psychologique
la ville du creusot met en place une
cellule psychologique
donc nous avons contacté les personnes
et nous allons continuer nous mettons
également nos services à disposition
pour les accompagner dans les démarches
administratives pour certaines personnes
qui auraient besoin en ce moment
également les équipes de gaz et
d'électricité sécuriser le secteur